foreign
[Music]
it is a mutual understanding of what
material gives us and how we can build
it I mean we don't pronounce the words
but we feel them while building up the
story and while building up the scenes
every eye flick every head shake they
all convey emotion I was came up with a
an expression which he used we used to
call poetic blue it's basically kind of
shorthand for layering kind of extra
information visually on top of the
picture so we see that collage of
different headlines to add extra
information to give to the audience
without adding time
[Music]
the way that worldwide audiences have
responded to top gun Maverick has been
far beyond anything that the cast and
crew dreamed of so thank you for
watching and I'm thrilled you enjoyed
the movie working with the access
performances and finding that balance
between light and dark comedian drama
and then finding and shaping the
sequences and the dialogue and the
scenes it was such a rewarding
experience one of the big challenges we
had was just kind of raining ourselves
in there was so much good material and
so much good improv on set and the first
cut we just threw it all in that was
kind of a struggle over the next
basically 11 months was deciding what
bits to lose and what bits to keep
because they were all great bits but
they couldn't all coexist together
the choices that are open to the editor
and how best to convey the story a
limitless
[Music]